[Music]
what was the last time you guys spent
a night in an airbnb like a month ago a
month ago a month ago
i don't have an airbnb account oh you
don't i should get one you should get
one
you're so aggressive i know you're like
okay i can help you get one if you want
sorry that was a surprise because i i
wasn't a part of the party of the airbnb
party
it was a family it was me and my parents
and my brother and my sister-in-law i
forgot that was airbnb
it was our first time seeing each other
since christmas was it your account
yeah did you book it on your account no
it was my sister-in-law's account
[ __ ] i should get an airbnb account you
should
you should get one what's up with you in
this account because i'm too famous
so i don't want people to know that i
got an airbnb
you can just put a fake name actually no
it's because um someone else always got
me airbnbs so i never had to deal with
it no
so it just became one of those things
where i just asked somebody to get it
and i vemble them
so then yeah that makes sense that's
basically what i do yeah and when i get
places
i use credit card points because they're
free
so i never actually stayed anywhere
outside of a hotel
because you can't you get [ __ ] mobbed
because you're so famous i'm [ __ ]
famous dude jesus that's like he's
wearing a hat right now just in case the
paparazzi walks in
and that's why i stay at loki hotels
because if i'm at fancy hotels that's
where they're looking for me yeah
i worked at a really fancy hotel i
always had a-list celebrities and stuff
and they always stayed under pseudonyms
and it was kind of cool because some of
them would get creative like
um the guy from green day stayed as sam
pellegrino really joel
yeah how'd they do that though how did
they book a room under that name
well they probably wouldn't have type in
their credit card i don't know
actually how they go can you confirm
your id you don't have an id you can't
stay here
it might be there are representatives
that book it and then yeah
and why why not use the representative's
name um
i don't know i think maybe they like
maybe they like having their pseudonym
you know yeah how come there's a pee in
front of it
that's my favorite thing to do is go to
chinese restaurants that have waiting
lists
and then i get to write whatever oh
that's you always used to do that yeah
what did you write i don't know just
random stuff like two live crew
you're like i don't know sifu chan or
something and then they could just come
out
excuse me table four for c for chen
say whatever the hell i want like
picking bowling names yeah it makes me
so happy
but yeah the reason why i bring up
airbnb is because as a company they have
officially
banned all house parties worldwide and
it is a company-wide policy now
and um this is attack on the parties
yeah it is an attacking party it just
happened you didn't see it on the news
what's next dancing
yeah what happened on the night
dancing's illegal in japan this is a
slippery slope
it's gonna it's gonna remember there was
a dancing police bit we did with the
then
the club laws they're they're like after
this time you cannot dance
you need a dancing permit yeah that's
true
now we need to have partying permits and
airbnb but what was going on i forgot
what city it was in but it is american
yeah it was here for sure america uh it
was airbnb they booked it this mansion
they had this party
uh and then people got shot at this
party it was but it was just so
[ __ ] small it wasn't even a pandemic
related thing it was just
but it is because it was just a lot of
people like they were packed in this
mansion
uh and then the final straw was they
shot somebody how many people was
considered a party
three i think because nice company i
think we just do low low key hang sashes
mostly
true like 10 10 people at a time kind of
thing i think the rule in california is
10 or less that's a party no it's how
much you're allowed to hang out with
i have that number here from airbnb the
holiday rental company has introduced
the property
uh occurrence cap of 16 people and whoa
that's pretty cool
yeah that's actually really big you can
have california it's 10 people
that's true i want to be the person at
the party
kind of like a bouncer but not really
the bouncer because you have to enforce
[ __ ]
but i want to be the guy that stands in
front of the club and they're like
you you you now you um
and you come on you want to be paid to
be judgmental and then they're like
he doesn't work here i don't know why
[Laughter]
go back put on some shoes bro okay come
on in
he's like i have shoes on
i don't have shoes on
we just booked our uh so every year we
have a barbell retreat
and we have about 30 people going and we
were able to book something
oh nice i don't know how recent this is
this was published august 20th
today as of today uh recording this
video it's august 21st
oh is this pandemic related stuff yeah
it's been it's definitely pandemic
related so
they're basically saying you know airbnb
has already taken a lot of steps to curb
you know the spread of the virus and all
these things a lot of
properties have also listed their own
like house rules and stuff
so like no partying limiting the number
of people
but up until now airbnb hasn't been able
to actually do anything
legally or whatever and and basically
what they're saying now is and i
actually don't know what happened for
them to be able to do it now
due to the way the company works it
really it couldn't really stop parts
from taking place
with guests often checking into
properties alone and inviting people
over so
people are getting away partying but now
guests won't be able to
break the rules so flagrantly with
airbnb saying it will pursue legal
action if guests or hosts break the
rules so they're just taking it one step
further now
and they will sue or whatever you know
whatever it is against the houses or the
the guests so yeah you ever seen those
um you ever seen those videos though
where the airbnb owners try to kick out
the
the renters and they won't leave and
they just like squat in the
in their house and that person's house
and they just take over and there's no
law there
yeah be kicked out because of the weird
tenant laws uh they had they couldn't
legally get them kicked out
i got a great idea i want to be an
evictor
like a repo person but then instead
you're just kicking people out of the
houses oh my god if they need my help
hey if you can need some someone to help
you evict some people i'll [ __ ] do it
what do you do as a new what's your
method
yeah sell me sell me the idea pitch me
dude i'm so petty i had to fill the
house with water frankly
that's a lot of water damage you don't
want to damage your own water so like
um that was fast there's a lot of dogs
that need care and love at the dog pound
that are just kind of troublesome right
and they like to bite people so we let
we borrow them and we unleash
20 of them into the house so you get to
go to the dock and go you
you you open the door you open the door
not you yeah they terrorize the people
bite them a couple times
and then they're gonna walk are they not
biting you true
what if they're just nice dogs they
start licking everybody oh and also if a
dog
you go for the ones that are okay if a
dog bites someone in the state of
california to be put down
nobody oh yeah what the [ __ ] you already
gonna get put down in shelters it's
win-win-win
yep they could get adopted why give them
a week to live
oh [ __ ] that's a really good week too
you're selling me really hard
time's out i love dogs
you know what i'm a rider died i'mma
ride or die
so if they if they get bit by the dog
they leave the house right
and then i um call my friends in mexico
and i'd be like i'm bringing some dogs
wait who do you know in mexico
i'll make friends okay right okay i'll
make some
my future friends right i'll be like so
the business plan starts with making
friends first yeah
the business plan starts with buying a
ticket to mexico i'll ask bart to go to
mexico
why bar i just trust bart okay
i'll be like bart can you just go to
mexico real quick why i'm bringing you
some homies right now
and then he picks the mexicans you you
you
yeah you're my friend go take your shoes
off buddy
i don't like your mustache oh wait so
we're replacing the dogs with mexican
people no no those are the friends that
are gonna get the dogs eventually
if a dog bites a person and mexicans
don't
bite that strong so he needs strong
biters strong biters right yeah he
doesn't want the dogs to get put down so
we'll have a variety we'll have ankle
biting terriers we'll have pit bulls
we'll have
big old huskies great danes all kinds
they'll come in
terrorize the people and then even if
they don't they'll [ __ ] and piss
everywhere
which will make people want to leave
they'll leave
right and they're not going to call the
cops because they're already doing
something illegal which is squatting
so it's a win-win situation really good
you know what i would do i would play
the cars for kids [ __ ] jingle
bells for kids oh my god
i would just play that in a room like
next to them loud
they're out of there bro
you have it built into the walls for
anyone that tries to stay too long yeah
you just hit the great cars for kids
dude see in hell pal
there's so many great ideas i don't know
why people
just use the option of asking you don't
ask
people you force people even as a first
route you don't just
try asking first well i mean if
someone's
overstays their welcome don't you just
unleash your dogs on them
no oh i just love repo [ __ ] in general
repo [ __ ] is [ __ ]
fun to watch because you i mean you
basically have to
have to remove your humanity from a
little bit because these people are
always down in their luck and [ __ ]
but watching like repo guys just pull up
when somebody's at a gas station
like going through the quarter jar like
trying to afford to get enough gas
that's sad
yeah and the [ __ ] they come up they
link up and they [ __ ] drag it up the
street
backwards shit's [ __ ] ridiculous dude
and then poor people are like oh no i'm
even more [ __ ] now
shit's why i think i'm gonna start doing
that now instead of asking people to
leave like if people come over for a
barbecue and then it's kind of like you
guys overstayed you're welcome i'm just
gonna unleash
dogs but you already don't even tell us
what time to get there or
leave yeah well that's because i don't
know how to ask you guys to leave
and you say we're not invited we just
have to show up yeah what the [ __ ] it's
so conflicting
and you never host anything it didn't
win you guys
when i want you to leave i let the dogs
out to bite you
and the dogs won't get put down because
they'll get sent to mexico nope
they'll just be bart with 500 dogs since
i have known you you have honest living
in mexico
since i have known you you've hosted
nothing i used to host [ __ ]
all the time my house used to be the
whole thing that's really cool
dude was it you or was it your roommates
hosting it though
true i have no recollection
of invitating anybody in potato but
people just showed up
so his roommates hosted a lot of other
people hosted a lot of stuff
but also i think it was a tradition
because i had a big space too
but even then i had a small space we did
things much smaller space with small
space
i had a uh that little condo that we
were all in but other people
invitate me probably are you sure about
that i don't know
i just want to see what it's like when
joe hosts a thing i don't want to think
that would be
i'm fascinated by himself no assistance
from roommates
you should you should host something
this is the perfect time to do it he
lives by himself he won't do it
he's like i gotta get the dogs you guys
don't respect the quarantine and
we're in the middle of a pandemic you
guys are trying to gather at my house
oh we all have coveted no we yeah we're
all chill
yeah we've been quarantined that's why
we're here right now we temperature
check before we walk in the room
yeah mm-hmm what do you do yeah what
about you bro yeah
what about you do you have a barbecue
grill yeah
can i just go to your house
you have to bring lemons oh no there's
none growing right now bring an
unreasonable amount of lemon i would
have brought figs too but you know what
[ __ ] squirrels or something's eating
them all oh yeah
we have a fig tree next door actually we
have figs you want some yeah
uh there's fig beetles that get them the
birds get them and squirrels get them
it's like a war to get these figs on
that tree wait if you
move out of your place what are you
gonna do you're not gonna have a lemon
tree anymore that's like half of your
day
i don't i don't know i'll i'll pick
other people's lemons
okay that's that's pretty good
[Music]
you